un maire peut-il être condamné s'il
refuse de marier un étranger soumis à
une obligation de quitter le territoire
français c'est ce que devra
prochainement trancher la justice le 7
juillet dernier le maire de Béziers
Robert Ménard n'avait pas voulu marier
une Française et un Algérien car ce
dernier se trouvait en situation
illégale en France était défavorablement
connu des services de police et était
sous le coup d'une octave depuis août
2022 pour justifier sa décision le maire
de Béziers avait expliqué au Figaro il
va épouser une Française de 6 ans de
plus que lui déjà mère de trois enfants
ça sent le mariage blanc à plein nez les
deux fiancés avaient chacun
préalablement répondu à un questionnaire
et été interrogé séparément par le
parquet de Béziers qui n'avait relevé
aucune incohérence laissant penser à un
mariage blanc le procureur avait par
ailleurs rappelé à Robert Ménard qu'il
était obligé de célébrer cette union
puisque selon l'article 12 de la
Convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme il est impossible
d'interdire à une personne de se marier
sous prétexte de sa situation aux yeux
de l'administration un cas de figure que
le maire de Béziers avait qualifié du
Busque le gouvernement se plaint de ne
pas retrouver les individus qui doivent
être expulsés du territoire et là il va
y en avoir un dans ma mairie et je vais
devoir le marier il n'en est pas
question quelques jours plus tard le
préfet de l'Hérault avait demandé le
placement en centre de rétention
administrative de l'homme algérien avant
qu'il soit expulsé vers l'Algérie le 20
juillet dans la foulée du refus de
Robert Ménard le couple avait décidé de
déposer plainte contre le maire trois
députés et les filles accompagnés d'un
maire du même bord ont également fait un
signalement dans une lettre procureur
Robert Ménard s'expose à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et 75000 euros d'amende
[Musique]